>>> YO THIS IS "GROUP CHAT" I'M
GREGG IVORY ALONGSIDE LIV MOODS.
LIV, THE AILLL-STAR STARTERS CA
OUT, THEY ANNOUNCED THE RESERVES
TODAY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
LINEUPS?
>> NOTHING TOOK ME BY SURPRISE
WITH THE STARTERS.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF STRONG
OPINIONS ABOUT ANDREW WIGGINS AS
AN ALL-STAR STARTER, EYE KNOW IT
HITS TOO CLOSE TO HOME OPENER
FOREYOU GREGG BUT REMEMBER,
THESE ALL-STAR GAMES ARE ABOUT
EXCITEMENT, AGGRESSION AND
COMPETITIVENESS, REGARDLESS OF
THE NUMBERS YOU GOT TO BRING THE
GUYS THAT WILL BRING A FUN AND
ENTERTAINING GAME AND WIGGINS
MUST HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO THE
HATE BECAUSE HE SURE TURNED IT
UP AFTER HEARING THE OPINION S
ABOUT HIM.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING INSANE, I'VE
BEEN CASHING OUT ON HIM LEFT AND
RIGHT.
I'M NOT MAD ABOUT IT, I'M MAKING
MONEY OFF HIS PERFORMANCES
LATELY BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
OPINION S ABOUT HIM.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DO HAVE
OPINIONS BUT YOU GUYS BE EASY ON
MY GUY TWO-WAY WIGS.
I'D SAY ARGUABLY ONE OF THE BEST
TWO-WAY SHOOTING GUARDS IN THE
GAME.
SO JUST PUT SOME RESPECT ON MY
MAN'S NAME.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, LIV,
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE DO EVERY
WEEK, WE'RE HERE GIVING AWAY
LOCKS, GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND
JERSEYS, GET IN THE COMMENTS, I
NEED GIF'S AND EMOJIS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED --
>> -- WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
>> YOU WERE STILL KIND OF LATE
ON THAT.
>> SORRY!
>> WE GOT TO WORK ON THAT.
>> IT WILL GET BETTER, IT WILL
GET BETTER.
>> IT WILL GET BETTER.
BUT I'M GIVING OUT A JERSEY
RIGHT NOW.
WHY NOT?
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING AS ALWAYS.
AND I SEE FIRE FIGHTER MAN C
SAYS MY MAN GREGG, WHAT UP
BROTHER.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO SEE JACK BOY WHO SAYS,
LAKERS MONEY LINE, SUNS MONEY
LINE, WOLVES MONEY LINE, LET'S
BE GREAT TONIGHT.
LOVE THE ENERGY.
LOVE THE PARLAY.
THEREFORE YOU, JACKIE BOY 47
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE OF YOUR CHOICE.
LIV IT'S TNT THURSDAY WHICH
MEANS YEAR BETTING THE THREE BY
TWO.
QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE TWO
THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
LAST WEEK THE THREE BY TWO CASH
ONCE AGAIN IN THE
MINNESOTA/GOLDEN STATE GAME.
HERE IT IS.
LIV, IT WASN'T TWO WARRIORS, IT
WAS ACTUALLY TWO TIMBER WOLVES,
JADEN McDAN YES, MA'AM ANLZ MY
MAN THE FORMER WARRIOR DELOADING
FROM THE TOP.
USUALLY WE ASK WHICH TWO BY
THREE IS A LOCK BUT TODAY
FanDUEL IS WHIPPING UP SOMETHING
VERY, VERY SPECIAL, OFFERING A
THREE BY TWO PARLAY.
SO WE GOT THE PHOENIX SUNS
TAKING ON THE ATLANTA HAWKS AND
THE LOS ANGELES LAKERS TAKING ON
THE LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS AND
IT'S BOOSTED UP TO PLUS 350.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE WILL
HE TWO OR MORE THREE-POINTERS
MADE IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES
IN EACH OF THESE GAMES?
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US IF YOU
THINK THEY ARE HITTING AND IF
YOU ARE RIDING WITH US, LIV,
TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING HERE?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GONNA LIE,
THIS ONE IS GONNA BE A SWEAT,
OKAY.
THIS IS NOT AN EASY PARLAY WE'RE
GOING TO BE RIDING WITH TONIGHT.
BOTH CLIPPERS AND SUNS RANK TOP
FIVE IN PERIMETER DEFENSE.
I THINK DEFENSE WILL BE TIGHT ON
THE SHARP-SHOOTERS EARLY IN THE
GAME.
BUT WITH A VALUE OF PLUS 350 CAN
YOU REALLY RESIST IT?
I MEAN, WE LOVE SOME PLUS MONEY,
THEY'RE BOOSTING IT FOR US.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SWEATING  IT
OUT, NO DOUBT, BUT WHAT'S WRONG
WITH A GOOD SWEAT.
IT'S NOT A GOOD CASH OUT IF WE
DON'T SWEAT IT OUT, IT'S GOING
TO BE NICE, PLUS 350
>> I LIKE WHAT YOU DID THERE,
LIV, WE'RE GOING TO BE SWEATING
IT OUT, I'M RIGHT BEHIND YOU
SWEATING IT YOU BUT I'M IN THE
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW LOOKING FOR
LOCKS.
I SEE MAX IN THE COMMENTS
ROCKING WITH THE OVER TONIGHT.
OKAY.
I GOT GOAT GARDEN SAYING LET'S
GO SNOOPY.
HE SAID I'LL THROW A DOLLAR
I'M GONNA JUST GIVE OUT A HOODIE
RIGHT HERE TO ANYBODY I SEE.
DALE PRETE 1.
IS SAYING NO TO THE THREE BY
TWO.
BUT I'M STILL SHOWING LOVE TO
YOU AND GIVING YOU A HOODIE.
GUESS WHAT, WE ARE ALL -- WE ARE
ALL -- WE'RE GOING TO USE
REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY HERE, LIV, WE
GOT DALE PRETE SAYING NO TO THE
THREE BY TWO BUT GUESS WHAT
WE'RE ALL RIDING THE THREE BY
TWO PARLAY AND DELL PRETE WE'RE
SENDING YOU A HOODIE FOR GOOD
VIBES.
WE'RE RIDING.
YOU'RE HOME AND CONSIDERING IT,
JUST RIDE WITH US.
LIV, WE TALKED ALL-STAR STARTERS
EARLIER, PEOPLE THINK D BOOK GOT
SNUBBED.
HE'S NOT STARTING THIS YEAR SO
TODAY WE ASKED, HOW MANY POINTS
WILL D BOOK MAKE TONIGHT?
HOW MANY POINTS IS HE GOING TO
COOK UP TONIGHT?
THE LINE IS SITTING AT 29.5.
LET'S LOOK AT THE CURRENT ODDS.
LIV, DO YOU THINK D BOOK IS
GOING TO TRY TO PROVE THE
ALL-STAR VOTERS WRONG TONIGHT?
WHAT POINT PROP DO YOU HOOKIC?
>> OF COURSE HE IS, BOOKER
DROPPED 38 THE LAST TIME HE
PLAYED THE HAWKS SO HIM SCORING
30 PLUS WOULD NOT SURPRISE ME,
ESPECIALLY IF HE'S MOTIVATED TO
PROVE PEOPLE WRONG, THAT'S A GUY
I TRUST TO DO THAT.
BUT TONIGHT I'M REALLY LIKING
MIKAL BRIDGES, IN THE LAST 7 THE
HAWKS GAVE UP 8th MOST POINTS,
ALMOST 24 POINTS A GAME TO
OPPOSING SMALL FORWARDS AND
BRIDGES OVER ON THE LAST THREE,
LOVING THE SPOT FOR HIM, BRIDGES
OVER 13.5 POINTS, I REALLY LIKE
THIS SPOT I THINK HE HITS THIS
OVER SO I'M ROCKING WITH MIKAL
BRIDGES.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH MIKAL
I'M GOING TO GET TO THESE
COMMENTS.
AND THEN I'M GONNA HOP IN WITH
MY PICK.
MY BOY, MIKE B, MICHAEL BOLING
IS IN THE COMMENTS AND HE IS
SAYING HE LOVED ALL OF THE
PARLAYS COOKING UP.
MAD DODGERS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING BOOKER SCORING 36.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, MAD DODGER,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ZEKE
30 TO 35 FOR D BOOK.
LOVE THE VIBES FOR MY MAN D
BOOK.
I WANT TO LOOK AT THE GRAPHIC,
PLEASE PULL THAT BACK UP, I WANT
YOU TO LOOK AT KEVIN HUERTER
DOWN THERE SECOND TO THE BOTTOM,
OVER UNDER SITTING AT 12.5.
MY MAN SCORED 26 IN HIS LAST
GAME.
AND LIV, I HEARD TRAE YOUNG IS
QUESTIONABLE TONIGHT WITH A
SHOULDER INJURY SO IF HE IS
PLAYING, EVEN IF HE'S NOT
PLAYING, LOOK FOR HUERTER TO
GIVE BIFFING UP THE SHOTS
TONIGHT.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH HIM IN THE
OVER, LIV.
GAVE OUT THE HOODIES ALREADY.
SO IT'S TIME TO TALK MAJOR
MARKETS MONEY LINES AGAINST THE
SPREADS AND POINT TOTALS FOR
TONIGHT'S GAME.
LIV, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ODDS, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE?
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> YEAH I GOTTA RIDE WITH THE
SUNS TONIGHT TO COVER THE
SPREAD.
THE HAWKS RANKED BOTTOM SIX FOR
TOTAL POINTS ALLOWED PER GAME
AND SUNS RANKED TOP THREE IN
POINTS SCORED PER GAME.
I LIKE THE SUNS TO COVER THAT
FOUR.
HAWKS ARE 1-3 AGAINST THE SPREAD
IN THE HOME UNDERDOG AND SUNS
15-8 IN THE SPREAD ON THE ROAD.
I THINK THE SUNS ARE TOO GOOD ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL TO NOT
COVER AGAINST A HAWKS TEAM WITH
PRETTY WEAK DEFENSE.
SO GIVE ME PHOENIX MINUS FOUR.
>> LIV'S ROCKING WITH PHOENIX
MINUS FOUR.
LIV, I ACTUALLY LIKE THAT.
LET'S PULL THAT GRAPHIC BACK UP.
LAST WEEK I HOOKED UP A PARLAY
AND IT HIT.
SO I'M FEELING THE VIBES OF
DOING IT AGAIN.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE SUNS
ON THE ROAD IN THIS ONE.
I MENTIONED TRAE YOUNG NOT
PLAYING, MAYBE PLAYING, IT'S UP
IN THE AIR, I THINK THE SUNS ARE
THE MORE COMPLETE TEAM OUT THERE
IN PHOENIX.
AND THEN I ALSO, ALSO WANT YOU
GUYS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SACRAMENTO KINGS.
FACING MY, YES, MY GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SPREAD,
USUALLY THE SACRAMENTO KINGS
PLAY THE WARRIORS VERY, VERY
TOUGH.
AND THE SPREAD IS JUST TOO BIG
FOR ME TODAY.
SO I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE
KINGS SPREAD PARLAY WITH PHOENIX
SPREAD AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THIS ONE TO THE BANK.
LIV, HEY, LIV, LET ME GO TO THE
COMMENTS, BECAUSE I GOT TO GIVE
OUT SOME HOODIES.
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS, LIV, IF YOU WANT,
YOU CAN ALWAYS JUMP IN THE
COMMENTS, PULL OUT THAT HANDY
DANDY PHONE AND PULL UP THE
BLEACHER REPORT AND GET TO IT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE.
JC1030 SAYS BOOKER IS DROPPING
39 TONIGHT ON ATLANTA AND WILL
CONTINUE HIS HOT STREAK.
MEANWHILE CP3 WILL DISH OUT 12
ASSISTS.
SUNS ARE GOING TO GET THE WIN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE JRB 9 SAYS BURTON
EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS.
I LIKE THE CURVE BALL.
AS I MENTIONED YOU GUYS ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
ONE MORE SUNS MINUS FOUR OVER
235, AND GOLDEN STATE,
--
APPRECIATE THE WINNERS ONLY
RIGHT THERE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
WE TALKED MAKER MARKETS, NOW
LET'S TALK
LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP AND
NEED ALL OF YOU, EVERYBODY IN
THE COMMENTS TO TELL ME WHETHER
IT'S A LOCK OR IT'S NOT, LIV,
ARE YOU READY TO GET THIS START
SND
>> LET'S GET TO IT.
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP ANTHONY DAVIS TO HAVE
OVER 26.5 POINTS.
IT'S AT MINUS 114.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A LOCK OR NOT
A LOCK.
>> I DO THINK IT'S A LOCK.
IN THE LAST SEVEN CLIPPERS HAVE
GIVEN UP THE MOST POINTS TO
OPPOSING CENTERS AT 28 PER GAME.
I LOVE THIS PLAY, DAVIS 27 LAST
TIME HE PLAYED CLIPPERS, I THINK
HE WILL CONTINUE TO SCORE IN
SIMILAR FASHION, OVER 26.5, LOCK
FOR ANTHONY DAVIS.
>> LIV, I'M RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
JUST TO NAME OFF SOME OF ANTHONY
DAVIS' RECENT POINT TOTALS, 31,
27, 30, HAD 30 LAST NIGHT.
MY MAN'S BEEN LOOKING VERY
ASSERTIVE WITH NO LeBRON JAMES.
I THINK I'M GONNA ROCK WITH YOU
AND TAKE THE OVER IN THIS ONE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
DOMINGO25 SAYS A.D. IS A LOCK.
TO GO OVER 26.5.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
NEXT UP WE HAVE RUSSELL
WESTBROOK TO RECORD 10 OR MORE
ASSISTS.
IT'S AT MINUS 104 IS THIS IS
LOCK OR NOT?
>> YEAH I THINK THIS IS A LOCK.
I LIKE THIS PLAY OAR NOT THIS
SEASON HE'S AVERAGED 7.8 ASSISTS
PER GAME.
WITHOUT LeBRON JAMES IT
INCREASES TO 8.9.
WITH ANTHONY DAVIS THAT NUMBER
SITS AT 8.5 ASSISTS PER GAME.
I THINK HE'LL FEED THE BALL TO
DAVIS ALL NIGHT LONG AND HITTING
THIS NUMBER IN THE LAST TWO
MAKES ME THINK HIM AND DAVIS
HAVE KIND OF STARTED TO FIGURE
OUT THEIR GROOVE, THEY FOUND
THEIR CHEMISTRY, HE KNOWS HE'S
IN THE FACILITATOR SPOT AND
DAVIS IS SCORING AND HE'S
FEEDING IT TO DAVIS ALL NIGHT
LONG, I THINK IT'S A LOCK, LEAF
THE PLAY.
>> LIV, IT'S FUNNY.
IT'S FUNNY.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE THE
SHOW.
ME AND YOU ARE ON THE SAME WAVE
LENGTH.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE STEALING MY
NOTES BEFORE THE SHOW BECAUSE I
HAVE IT WRITTEN HERE, IN ORDER
FOR A.D. TO HAVE A GOOD GAME --
WE MENTIONED A.D. WILL BE
BALLING TODAY -- HIM AND
WESTBROOK WILL HAVE TO CONNECT A
LOT OF PICK-AND-ROLLS.
WESTBOOK GOT TO FEED A.D.
I COULD SEE WESTBROOK GOING OVER
10 ASSISTS AND WE ALSO GOT TO
MENTION NO LeBRON NO LeBRON SO
THE BALL CAN BE IN MY GUY
WESTBROOK'S HAND A LOT TONIGHT.
SO LET ME GO TO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME GO TO THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I SEE
PHOENIX1 SAYS I'M FADING
WESTBROOK.
WELL, THOSE ARE OPPOSITE VIBES
OF ME AND LIV, BUT GUESS WHAT
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH EYA
HOODIE PHOENIX1.
I ALSO HAVE BROHALLE SAYING DO
NOT LOCK IT IN.
TALKING ABOUT WESTBROOK BUT YOU
KNOW WE GIVE LOVE WHERE THERE'S
HATE OR DISAGREEMENT, OR, YOU
KNOW, CONFUSION, WHATEVER IT IS,
WHATEVER YOU MAY CALL IT, WE
GIVE LOVE TO THAT.
SO BOTH OF YOU GUYS ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH HOODIES.
AND FINALLY, FINALLY, WE HAVE
REGGIE JACKSON,
THREE OR MORE THREE-POINTERS
TONIGHT, LIV, IT'S SITTING AT
PLUS 215.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE, TALK TO ME.
IS THIS A LOCK OR NOT?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY NO.
HOWEVER, I DO LIKE REGGIE
JACKSON TO HAVE A BIG NIGHT
TONIGHT.
HE'S FACING A LAKERS TEAM THAT
IN THE LAST SEVEN HAVE GIVEN UP
THE THIRD MOST POINTS TO
OPPOSING POINT GUARDS AT NEARLY
29.
SO I LIKE THE SPOT FOR REGGIE
JACKSON TO DO SOME SCORING.
HOWEVER, THREES, NOT SO SURE.
ONE THING I DO KNOW HE WILL TAKE
THE SHOT REGARDLESS.
THERE'S HOPE IF YOU FEEL LIKE
SPRINKLING ON THIS PLAY.
HOWEVER THIS SAY LAKERS TEAM
WITH PRETTY DECENT PERMANENT
DEFENSE.
PERIMETER DEFENSE.
I DON'T LOVE THE THREES FOR HIM.
I THINK TAKE THE POINTS PLUS
ASSIST BECAUSE LAKERS HAVE BEEN
GIVING UP A LOT OF ASSISTS AS
WELL TO OPPOSING POINT GUARDS IN
THE LAST SEVEN.
I LIKE REGGIE TO HAVE A BIG
NIGHT.
NOT SURE IT'S FROM THE THREE
THOUGH.
SO I'M SAYING NOT A LOCK.
MAYBE HIS POINTS OR POINTS PLUS
ASSISTS WORTH YOUR MONEY.
>> LIV, I'M RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS A
LOCK.
THE ODD'S MAKERS DON'T THINK SO
EITHER, THAT'S WHY IT IS AT PLUS
215.
BUT, LIV, BUT, I WOULD SAY MY
MAN REGGIE JACKSON HAS HIT THIS
THREE OUT OF HIS LAST SIX GAMES,
THEREFORE, MAKING THIS
SPRINKLEABLE.
I THINK THAT'S THE WORD,
WE CAN ACTUALLY PUT SOME TYPE OF
MONEY ON THIS.
AND HOPE THAT THIS HITS.
BUT I'M NOT CALLING THIS ONE A
LOCK.
BUT IT IS REGGIE JACKSON.
I CONSIDER HIM, HE DOES HAVE
THAT DOG MENTALITY AND HE PUTS
UP THE SHOTS.
HE'S A BIG SHOT MAKER SO THIS IS
SPRINKLEABLE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M SEEING IF THEY ARE AGREEING
WITH THIS.
SEEING IF THEY ARE GOING THE
OTHER WAY.
I SEE J BUCKETS FOR THREE.
REGGIE MIGHT GET IT, IT'S A
LOCK.
SHOUT OUT.
PARKER SAYS REGGIE IS A LOCK,
HE'S A SNIPER, HE'S ALSO GIVEN
US A LOT OF FIRE EMOJI.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU TWO, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIES.
LIV, IT'S TIME TO BUILT THE B/R
BETTING CUSTOM SAME-GAME PARLAY
WHICH YOU CAN RIDE WITH US ON
FanDUEL.
WE'RE LOOKING TONIGHT AT
SUNS/HAWKS GAME AND I NEED
EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME WHAT THEY THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS, WHICH LEGS
ARE NOT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP, WE'RE STARTING OFF
WITH THE POINT GOD HIMSELF, LIV,
CP3.
IS HE GOING TO SCORE 15 OR MORE
POINTS TONIGHT?
I THINK YES.
LIV, TALK TO US NICE, DO YOU
THINK YES?
>> A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT THIS
ONE, NOT GONNA LIE, YOU KNOW, I
THINK HE'S GONNA DO EXACTLY WHAT
WE NEED HIM TO DO IN ORDER FOR
DEVIN BOOKER TO HIT 30 PLUS
POINTS AND HE'S GOING TO
FACILITATE.
I DON'T THINK SCORING WILL BE
HIS MAIN PRIORITY TONIGHT.
DOESN'T MEAN HE WON'T GET
BUCKETS BUT I THINK GUYS LIKE
BOOKER AND BRIDGES WHO ARE
FACING A HAWKS TEAM THAT DOESN'T
DEFEND SMALL FORWARDS VERY WELL,
THEY'RE IN A BETTER SPOT TO ME
TO BE SCORING THAN CHRIS PAUL
IS, HOWEVER, CHRIS PAUL IS A
ASSISTS, THAT'S ANOTHER STORY,
AND WE'LL GET TO THAT OBVIOUSLY.
BUT WITH THE POINTS, I'M A
LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT IT.
OBVIOUSLY HE CAN GET THEM.
I DON'T DENY THAT HE'S TALENTED
ENOUGH TO SCORE 15 PLUS BUT I
THINK IN THIS SPOT I LIKE DEVIN
BOOKER TO BE THE GUY.
WHO IS GOING TO GET DEVIN BOOKER
INVOLVED?
CHRIS PAUL.
SO I LIKE HIM IN MORE OF A
FACILITATING SPOT.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
NEVER KNOW WITH CHRIS PAUL.
HE BRINGS THE HEAT WHEN HE NEEDS
TO
>> LIV, SPEAKING OF THE WAVE
LENGTHS AND THE GOOD VIBES, YOU
MENTIONED CHRIS PAUL
FACILITATING TONIGHT.
>> I DID.
>> THAT'S THE NEXT LEG OF THE
PARLAY.
CHRIS PAUL TO RECORD 12 PLUS
ASSISTS.
YOU SEE HOW THE DOTS ARE
CONNECTING HERE, LIV.
>> I SEE THEM.
>> TALK TO ME, TALK TO THE
PEOPLE, DO YOU LIKE THIS PART OF
THE PARLAY?
THIS LEG OF THE PARLAY?
>> I DO.
I REALLY LIKE THIS.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO BE IN
FULL FACILITATOR MODE TONIGHT
FEEDING THE BALL TO BOOKER SO
BOOKER CAN CASH ON THE 30-PLUS
POINTS, YES, I THINK HE WILL
SCORE 30 PLUS.
SO YEAH, PAUL, IN THIS SPOT LOVE
HIM IN THE OVER, GREAT LEG.
>> YES,
YES, YES.
WE ARE MOVING ON WITH THE GOOD
VIBES.
JOHN COLLINS TO SCORE 15 OR MORE
POINTS TONIGHT, LIV, TALK TO ME,
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
OR DO YOU NOT?
>> MENTIONED IT EARLIER, WE HAVE
I QUESTIONABLE TRAE YOUNG AND IF
THERE'S ANY GUY ON THIS HAWKS
TEAM THAT I WOULD TRUST JUST
BENEATH TRAE YOUNG IT'S A GUY
LIKE JOHN COLLINS I THINK IT'S A
GOOD SPOT FOR HIM TO STEP INTO
THE LEADERSHIP ROLE IF YOUNG IS
NOT PLAYING.
HE IS A AGGRESSIVE AND
COMPETITIVE PLAYER, AND I THINK
IT WILL BE BOTH THOSE THINGS
THIS ENTIRE GAME WILL BE
AGGRESSIVE AND COMPETITIVE AND
JOHN COLLINS IS THE GUY ON THE
HAWKS TEAM TO GET THE JOB DONE
SO I LOVE THIS.
I THINK HE COULD SCORE HALF
THESE POINTS FROM THE
THREE-POINT LINE, DRIVING  IT
INTO THE BASKET, DRAWING THE
FOUL, BECAUSE HE DOES PLAY WITH
AGGRESSION THAT I LOVE TO WATCH,
SO JOHN COLLINS 15 PLUS I REALLY
LIKE THIS.
>> OKAY.
FEELING THE GOOD J, JU.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE FINAL LEG.
WE TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER, YOU
GAVE US YOUR SIDE BUT I WANT YOU
TO RE-TOUCH THIS ONE, THIS IS
DEVIN BOOKER TO SCORE 25 PLUS
POINTS.
DO YOU TAKE MY GUY D BOOK TO
CASH THIS LEG ON THE PARLAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY YES.
HE HAD 38 THE LAST TIME HE PLAYS
THE HAWKS.
LIKE YOU SAID, PLAYING WITH A
LITTLE CHIP ON HIS SHOULDER,
TRYING PROVE THE HATERS WRONG.
SO YES, 25 PLUS FOR BOOKER DON'T
WANT TO SAY LOCK BUT IT FEELS
LIKE A LOCK.
LOVE THIS ONE.
>> LIV LIKES IT.
I LIKE IT.
LET'S PUT THE TICKET UP.
WE WAS TO PUT DOWN $100, WE'D
WALK AWAY WITH $522.63.
IF YOU PUT $100 ON THIS SAME
GAME PARLAY THE ODDS PLUS 522.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE COMMENTS
AND THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING,
WHAT ARE YOU GRADING THIS SAME
GAME PARLAY?
>> B MINUS.
I LIKE IT.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT PARLAY.
CHRIS PAUL SCORING TONIGHT IS
THE ONLY ONE THAT I'M FEELING A
LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT.
AND IF WE DO HEAR THAT AT THE
LAST SECOND TRAE YOUNG IS
PLAYING, I THINK THAT TAKES AWAY
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLINS TO SCORE.
SO WELCOME TO THE NBA WHERE
THERE'S LATE SCRATCHES AND
GAME-TIME DECISIONS AND IT JUST
MAKES YOSWEAT YOUR PARLAY OUT TT
MUCH MORE.
WHAT'S NOT A GOOD BET WITHOUT A
GOOD SWEAT.
WE'RE FINE.
WE'RE ROCKING WITH IT, SWEATING
IT OUT, B MINUS, STILL PASSING.
>> LIV, SAYING WE'RE GOING TO BE
PUTTING IN THE WORK TONIGHT
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
SWEATING.
>> YES.
>> Y'ALL GET READY TO SWEAT
TONIGHT, SWEAT THESE BETS OUT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND ALSO
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
I GOT ONE HARLEY SINGER,
JERMAINE, GAVE US A B.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU ONE HARLEY
SINGER.
I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO HOOK YOU
UP WITH A JERSEY FOR YOUR GRADE.
BECAUSE B, ABSOLUTELY, GET
DEGREES AND B'S CAN GET YOU ON
THE HONOR ROLL SO SHOUT OUT TO
YOU YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
JERSEY.
ENDER MAN IS IN THE COMMENTS
GIVING GREAT, GREAT INSIGHTS.
LISTEN TO THIS, HE SAYS LOCK IT
IN.
CP 3 WILL FACILITATE AND SCORE
TODAY.
HE'S BEEN THE FOURTH QUARTER
KING AND POINT GOD.
JC IS GOING TO STEP UP IF TRAE
IS OUT TONIGHT.
D BOOK IS GOING TO HAVE AT LEAST
25 POINTS.
HE HAS BEEN GOING ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY.
ESPECIALLY AFTER FEELING LIKE HE
SHOULD BE AN ALL-STAR.
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
THAT DESERVES A JERSEY.
LOVE THE INTAKE.
I GOT ONE SAYING
GREGG, I AM TRYING TO WIN A
JERSEY TODAY I BET ON ALL OF
THEM.
LOCK IT UP.
SENDING YOU GOOD VIBES AND THE
JERSEY.
ONE MORE.
NASH SAYS 15 PLUS POINTS SHOULD
BE ON INSTEAD.
I THINK LIV TALKED ON MIKAL
BRIDGES, SO I'M LIKING THE
CONNECTION, LIKING THE
CONNECTION.
RICH, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
A HOODIE.
OKAY.
LIV, LET'S TALK FUTURES.
THE PHOENIX SUNS ARE ON AN
11-GAME WIN STREAK AND THEY'RE
MAKING A RUN AT THE WEST.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF YOU
THINK THE SUNS CAN OVERTAKE THE
WARRIORS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS TO WIN THE WEST.
LIV, YOUR NUGGETS ARE LOOKING
LIKE A LONG SHOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF PHOENIX
CREEPING UP ON GOLDEN STATE?
>> I THINK, YOU KNOW, THEM
CREEPING UP IN THE ODDS
RIGHTFULLY  SO.
THEY'RE PLAYING VERY WELL RIGHT
NOW AND THAT'S WITHOUT A FULLY
HEALTHY TEAM.
I KNOW WE'VE HAD AYTON AND
CROWDER IN AND OUT OF GAMES HERE
AND THERE.
SUNS ARE PLAYING WELL AND
DESERVE TO BE SITTING WHERE THEY
ARE, THEY SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
THE FAVORITE RIGHT NOW OVER THE
WARRIORS BUT I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THE NUGGETS AND GREAT
VALUE, BUT MY SENDERELA STORY,
SLEEPER TEAM THIS YEAR IS THE
MEMPHIS GRIZZLIES.
I CAN'T SAY IT ENOUGH.
THIS TEAM IS SO TALENTED.
.
THEY HAVE GUYS LIKE JJJ ON THE
DEFENSIVE SIDE OF THINGS.
THEY GOT THE BIG MAN IN STEVEN
ADAMS.
DESMOND BANE FROM THE THREE.
JA MORANT ONE OF THE MOST
EQUIV
ELECTRIC AND EXCITING POINT
GUARDS TO WATCH.
THIS TEAM IS STACKED AND EVEN
WITHOUT THEIR BEST PLAYER JA
MORANT THEY WERE STILL WINNING
GAMES.
I LOVE THE WAY THEY'RE PLAYING,
THEY'RE A HIDDEN GEM, TO GRAB
THEM AT THAT VALUE IS
INCREDIBLE.
FORGIVE ME FOR SAYING THIS,
MIGHT BE A HOT TAKE BUT I COULD
SEE THE PHOENIX SUNS CHOKING IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
SORRY IF YOU'RE A SUNS FANS, I
THINK THEY'RE GREAT, BUT I CAN
SEE THEM CHOKING IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
I'M REALLY LIKING WARRIORS AND
GRIZZLIES, FINAL TWO IN THE
WEST, BATTLING IT OUT.
THIS GRIZZLIES TEAM TO ME IS
DEFINITELY A SUPER TEAM AND
WORTH THE MONEY AT PLUS 1300
>> LIV, I'LL BE HONEST.
IF I'M SPRINKLING THE BOARD ON
THE WEST, ON WHO GOING TO WIN
THE WEST I'M RIGHT BEHIND YOU,
TAKING THIS AND SHOWING A LOT OF
GRIT.
YOU MENTIONED JA WENT OUT.
THEY STILL SHOWED THAT MEMPHIS
GRIT.
THAT MEMPHIS MENTALITY AND STILL
CAPTURED WINS.
JA IS BACK.
THEY'RE PLAYING REALLY WELL.
THEY'RE WORTH THE SPRINKLE.
I MEAN, PLUS 1300, THEY'RE WORTH
THE SPRINKLE, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT A TEAM THAT I'VE BEEN
ROCKING WITH SINCE THE BEGINNING
AND I'M NOT FALTERING AND I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE TO ROCK WITH
IS THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
LIV, THEY TOOK A BUMP IN THE
ROAD NOT TOO LONG AGO, COUPLE
WEEKS AGO EVERYBODY WAS
WONDERING, HEY, WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE WARRIORS, KLAY CAME
BACK, NO DRAYMOND, EVERYONE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE WARRIORS.
THEY CALMED EVERYBODY DOWN AND
STARTING TO WIN GAMES.
THEY'RE STILL FIGURING IT OUT.
KLAY JUST CAME BACK FROM A
LENGTHY, LENGTHY ABSENCE AND
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GEL WITH ONE
ANOTHER ONCE AGAIN.
BUT ONCE THEY GET THAT MOLD
TOGETHER, ONCE THEY GET THAT
CHEMISTRY GOING, I THINK THE
SKY'S THE LIMIT FOR THIS TEAM.
DRAYMOND GREEN'S COMING BACK.
JAMES WISEMAN IS SUPPOSED TO BE
BACK.
KLAY THOMPSON IS LOOKING KIND
OF, SORT OF LIKE THE KLAY OF
OLD, BUT HE'S GETTING BACK INTO
GAME SHAPE, I WOULD SAY.
BUT LOOK OUT FOR THAT GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS TEAM, DO NOT
COUNT THEM OFF, ESPECIALLY IF
THE LOS ANGELES LAKERS CONTINUE
TO LOOK HOW THEY'RE LOOKING
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S THE ONLY TEAM I COULD SEE
IN THE SEVEN-GAME SERIES THAT
COULD GIVE THIS GOLDEN STATE
TEAM TROUBLE.
WATCH OUT FOR THOSE LAKERS.
LIV, RIGHT NOW, I AM IN THE
COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND I
SEE
-- I SEE Y AYE SAYS --
WARRIORS HAVE THE EASIER
REMAINING SCHEDULE.
SUNS, TRAFFIC.
ONCE KLAY GETS BACK AND THE
CHEMISTRY, LET ME GET A JERSEY.
I CAN'T GIVE YOU A JERSEY BUT I
CAN GIVE YOU A HOODIE SHOUT OUT
TO YOU FOR  WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
DOMINGO 25 SAYS THE SUNS HAVE
PLAYOFF EXPERIENCE, THEY CAN GET
BACK TO WHERE THEY WERE LAST
YEAR SHOUT OUT TO YOU DOMINGO
THAT ALSO DESERVES A HOODIE
BECAUSE I FEEL THE SAME WAY.
--
IF CURRY STAYS SLUMPING THEN THE
SUNS COULD TAKE THE WEST.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, THAT COULD
ABSOLUTELY HAPPEN IF OCCUR
SLUMPS.
ONE MORE.
EVERY PLAYER HAS A PICK ROLL
THAT HELPS THE TEAM.
THAT'S FROM NOT STEPH CURRY.
YES, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TAKE.
EVERYBODY I MENTIONED IS WALKING
AWAY WITH HOODIES, LIV, I'M
ABOUT TO TAKE THIS, GO HOME,
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
"GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FanDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY,
THE THREE BY TWO PARLAY WE ARE
ALL RIDING, IT IS A LOT.
GET ON FanDUEL TO TELL OUR B/R
BETTING SAME DAY PARLAY.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY
GIVING OUT HOODIES AND MORE
JERSEYS AND MORE LOCKS AND
HOPEFULLY LIV WILL BE SAYING THE
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE PRAISE BUT
WE'LL SEE, BUT IF YOU WON A
HOODIE TODAY, GOOD FOR YOU, I'M
GREGG IVORY ALONGSIDE LIV MOODS.